there's donut day there's pizza day 2013
was the International Year of quinoa and
I love Kenan
I really do a whole year like how do you
even celebrate I've always been inspired
by regular people who decide to follow
their passion and in doing so end up
having a positive impact on the world
figure than they could have ever
imagined one of those people is my
friend Hank Porter
you started a holiday yes tell me about
that it actually came about only because
it didn't exist I think sometimes making
an impact feels a lot for people like I
got I want to be a part of that or I
want to be a part of that I want to be a
part of that you can stand out just by
looking going what is nobody paying
attention to or what does everybody
think is already being done I had a big
personal experience with adoption after
three of us biologically my parents
fostered 36 kids over a seven-year
period we had an amazing family unit
that focused on taking care kids that
didn't have family family we never had
anything to do with last names or blood
or color or DNA it was always who was in
our home that we were taking care of
that's who family was we kind of slammed
our face into the system which is not
serving kids well I had a little brother
for three years his name is hobby and
just an unbelievable unbelievable kid
and we bonded super super fast he was
with us for three years and then we got
a phone call and within 24 hours the
police and social worker came to take
him out of our home so take a 6 year old
two year old four year old when they
enter the system send them through
different sets of parents and Families
you don't remember every house you just
know the world is gonna use me or pass
me around they turn 18 they're handed a
trash bag full of their items most the
time sometimes there's great programs
the YMCA and YWCA creates some really
great programs but for a minority of
these kids most of them end up
unemployed most of them end up in prison
that part of the journey was super
difficult for me and which is part of
these in what shifted our family into
the permanence of adoption so we had
seven years of foster care and then they
proceeded to do ten years of adoption
and we adopted eight kids from six
different countries
all right so we see where your drive for
adoption comes from and then from that
you you went and you started an
organization called adopt together yep
adopt together was started as a platform
that helps families fundraise for their
adoption okay we realized it's so
expensive it can be upwards of forty to
fifty thousand dollars to adopt
domestically if you're a teacher or a
cop if you make fifty or sixty grand a
year they're like I'll take a year's
salary in cash you know what's the
percentage of people that have that yeah
eighty-seven percent of people who
consider adoption they just bail so we
hope that people might look at the price
tag and go it's a sign of shouldn't
adopt but they look at adopt together
and go okay it's a sign we showed a dog
from what point after starting your
foundation did you realize hey let's
turn this thing into a holiday I have a
friend named Scott Harrison who started
charity:water been an amazing support
but also a mentor in the process and
every time I would tell him about what I
was doing he would always say throw a
party as it turns out you need basically
cool parties to raise money in the world
so we're about to hit our five millionth
dollar it's just massive success for us
that was like way beyond what we'd
imagined so we started that in 2012 and
then in 2013 we were like we got to
figure out how to celebrate we got to
throw a party so I was like God will do
something around world Adoption Day and
we're sitting in a room talking about
the parties and I finally said hey guys
somebody Google when World Adoption Day
is and we'll just do it around world
adoption eight because there has to be a
world that has to exist right there
sitting there and I can't find it I'm
like okay could I have the computer
other make sure you have the internet
works I'm hooking and I make like a fool
of this person and then I'm like
standing there and like the pressures
cooking cuz I'm like I could not find
the world adoption day and I was like we
know what to do now we're gonna create
World Adoption Day and then I looked at
a guy is like hey find out if the domain
is available which of course there's no
such thing so yes the domain was
available so we started the domain got
one of the guys at the table was like
hey I'm gonna build a site we built a
site that night drew everything up
rocked it and just said alright we got
to do it I started calling people and
saying hey we're gonna create World
Adoption Day and one of the guys was
like yeah I think you should touch base
with the UN because they sort of do that
yeah and I was like definitely yeah dude
that was that was all my list so I
called the UN and I just said hey I'd
like to submit a day for International
observance which I was like super proud
of myself for knowing how to say that
statement and he said woah are you an
ambassador
you better believe it I'm an ambassador
for world adoption and he's like doing
are you a delegate yes I have delegated
myself to make this phone call to you
the guy was like that's not how this
works your dad he gives me like this
line about how hard it is and how long
it takes and you gotta eat these people
I go cool then I'm just gonna do it cuz
we already picked a day which I was
gonna tell you about it's November 9th
and he's like okay yeah if you can do it
but it won't be real then I was like no
offense but this is the International
you of quinoa and I'm the only person
that I know who knows so I can make it
real then you and I work out the
logistics later and he's like fine
good luck so we needed some activation
we needed some way to communicate to
people that they were celebrating he
gives people a way to celebrate and a
lot of ideas came up and I loved a lot
of art history and how art has impacted
culture and there's a story of a guy
named Harvey ball Harvey was an artist
and like 50 years ago who created the
smiley face and I remembered that story
and remember those pieces and somebody
said we need a visual
we need an icon we need what is what is
World Adoption Day and for me having
come from a world where adoption was
such a tragic story to begin with you
don't come to adoption because
everything is going smoothly yeah you
come to adoption because a birth mother
tragically is either not well we're not
capable or able or of her own volition
says I just can't no I cannot give this
child life so a child and their mother
are separated that's the beat that's
where adoption starts which is tragic
what adoption does is it redeems that
brokenness it it brings a healing and a
hope and a joy and a celebration so I
said let's draw a smiley face on
people's hands and have them post a
selfie oh and say happy world adoption
day I wanted to raise I love that feel
good no as soon as you see it you're
smiling yeah if your everything can suck
around you but for one day everybody's
gonna say family is everything every
child deserves a family and we're gonna
boost morale around this conversation
that has otherwise been taboo or awkward
or uneasy and you get to celebrate
people but we got yacked opposed and so
it got people pumped and excited since
then we've have Ellen and Charlie's
their own and so many people who
lives have been touched and they've
posted the smiley face it's a hundred
percent participation anybody can
participate and vote for families and
vote for kids to have a home I wanted to
change the way that people imagine
family and the amount of people who
posted this who said hey I'm adopted
I've never told my story I've never told
my family how grateful for I am for them
people who posted and said I have a
little brother who's adopted I've never
told people that and it's just
extraordinary for me to go even though
all these stories began with tragedy
somewhere yeah for one day we're just
gonna celebrate that because of those
tragedies I have my brother Brendan and
Matthew and hope and gab like I have
these people in my life because of that
tragedy and for one day I'm going to
celebrate it he basically started a
movement hopefully hopefully
[Music]
[Applause]